[Musik]
>> SALLY: Ich habe eine Vision!
Ich werde einen Veggie-Burger machen.
Und ich glaube, er wird nicht nur vegetarisch, sondern vegan.
Und er wird der Hammer!
Und ich habe gerade so viele Ideen in meinem Kopf.
Ich muss sie kurz aufmalen.
Und dann entscheiden wir mit Josh, was wir machen. Okay?
Okay.
Also er wird vegan, ja?
Das ist ein grünes Blatt.
Also es wird ein Burger.
Das heißt, wir haben den Burger Bun hier.
Und was dazwischen passiert, weiß ich noch nicht.
Aber ich weiß, dass wir
den Pattie aus Gemüse machen
hier.
Yes!
Und ich weiß auch schon wie.
Aus Gemüseresten so, wie wir es mit Volkan immer machen.
Und unten
Spinat,
ganz viel Babyspinat.
Und jetzt ist die Überlegung:
Machen wir den Burger Bun auch mit Spinat,
dass es ein grüner, ein grünes Brötchen wird?
>> JOSH: Coole Idee!
>> SALLY: Schon.
>> JOSH: Oder vielleicht sogar rot mit Roter Bete?
>> SALLY: Oder Rote Bete.
Hach!
Oder...
Aber das hatte ich schon mal.
Ich hatte aus Roter Bete praktisch so Spirellis reingemacht so.
Das sieht auch gut aus.
Oh, ich glaube,
vielleicht machen wir rote Zwiebeln und Rote Bete
hier so als Spirelli so angebraten.
Weil das sieht echt gut aus.
Oder wir probieren beides.
Ich mache praktisch einmal Rote-Bete-Buns und grüne Buns
und dann kann man ja so
– oh ja! –
sie unterschiedlich belegen.
Du weißt, was ich meine?
>> JOSH: Ja, ich weiß, was du meinst.
>> SALLY: Das heißt, bei den Rote-Bete-Nudeln
würde ich den Bun
grün machen.
Und hier drüben...
>> JOSH: Können wir vielleicht
sogar Rote Bete ins Pattie reinmachen,
dass das so ein bisschen rot wird?
>> SALLY: Ja, das können wir auch.
>> JOSH: Dann könnte man den mit grünem Bun
mit rotem Pattie.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> JOSH: Und den mit grünem Pattie...
>> SALLY: Also hier jetzt praktisch rot?
>> JOSH: So ein bisschen Rot rein. Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Trotzdem Spinat, nicht?
Ich finde, Spinat ist so...
>> JOSH: Ja, auf jeden Fall!
>> SALLY: Okay. Aber, wenn das rot ist,
da drauf dann
eher wieder was Helles.
Vielleicht Karotten so,
>> JOSH: Mmh!
>> SALLY: geraspelte.
>> JOSH: Das ist cool!
>> SALLY: Und das Burgerbrötchen?
Eigentlich...
>> JOSH: Da würde Natur passen theoretisch.
>> SALLY: Natur.
Okay. Jetzt haben wir zwei Rezepte gemacht.
>> JOSH: Oh, jetzt brauchen wir ja noch das dritte
mit dem roten,
mit einem roten Brötchen.
>> SALLY: Ach, Mist! Ja.
Wir haben zu viele Ideen.
Wir entscheiden uns jetzt für eine Variante, würde ich sagen.
Kannst du dich entscheiden?
>> JOSH: Das grüne Brötchen ist schon cool.
>> SALLY: Das ist schon cool, gell?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Wir machen grüne Brötchen.
Okay. Los geht's!
Wir backen jetzt grüne Burger Buns!
>> JOSH: Oh!
Mir fällt noch was auf.
>> SALLY: Hm?
>> JOSH: Wir müssen noch die Soße besprechen.
>> SALLY: Ja!
Ich glaube, als Soße
machen wir einfach eine Crème fraîche
in vegan
mit Schnittlauch.
Hier
so runtertropfen
und hier.
Und hier.
Oh yes!
Und da oben.
Mein veganer Burger!
Nicht nur für Veganer geeignet!
Also die Entscheidung ist gefallen.
Es werden Spinat-Burger-Buns.
Und ich hoffe, sie funktionieren so auch ganz gut.
Für den Hefeteig verwende ich
einen Würfel Hefe,
30 Gramm Zucker,
300 Gramm warmes Wasser,
200 Gramm vegane Milch,
Hafer- oder Mandelmilch zum Beispiel,
300 Gramm frischen Spinat,
500 Gramm Mehl,
zwei Teelöffel Salz
und 50 Gramm Sonnenblumenöl.
Was ich jetzt zuerst mache, ist,
die Hefe im Wasser auflösen.
Wenn ihr sagt, ihr möchtet den Teig am Tag zuvor vorbereiten,
dann nehmt die Hälfte der Hefemenge.
Das reicht dann auch aus.
Im Prinzip müsst ihr einfach nur beachten:
Je weniger Hefe, umso länger ist die Gehzeit.
Und je mehr Hefe, umso schneller habt ihr ein Ergebnis.
Aber manche mögen einfach keinen Hefengeschmack
– Hefegeschmack.
Und dann nehmen sie einfach weniger
und lassen es länger gehen.
Ist dann auch bekömmlicher.
Aber ich persönlich muss sagen, mich stört es nicht.
Jetzt hier einfach mit dem Zucker verrühren.
Und jetzt werde ich die zwei Flüssigkeiten,
also Hefe und vegane Milch, also Pflanzenmilch,
und Spinat einfach kurz pürieren.
Wenn ihr jetzt keine vegane Milch dahabt,
wie Mandelmilch oder Hafermilch,
nehmt einfach stattdessen Wasser.
Funktioniert auch super.
Ich gebe jetzt alles kurz in den Mixer.
Das mache ich allerdings ganz kurz da hinten.
Ich brauche jetzt im Prinzip einfach nur die Flüssigkeit,
damit der Spinat zerkleinert wird.
Ich habe jetzt hier frische Spinatblätter.
Die oberen, die hatte ich eingefroren,
aber selber.
Das Problem bei tiefgefrorenem Spinat, den ihr kauft,
ist nämlich, dass zu viel Wasser drin ist.
Das heißt, wenn ihr TK-Spinat benutzt,
einfach die Flüssigkeit ausdrücken
beziehungsweise einfach die Wassermenge dann reduzieren.
Ihr könnt es ja dann im Prinzip auch einfach zusammenrechnen.
Und dann passt es auch.
Es muss ja später einfach nur
mit der Mehlmenge sozusagen stimmen
und keinen zu flüssigen Teig ergeben.
So.
Das kurz pürieren,
ganz fein.
[Musik]
Das ist jetzt echt irgendwie so ein Vorurteil,
dass jetzt diese veganen Burgerbrötchen
einfach auch so grün sind.
Oh! Ein Spinatblatt hat es nicht geschafft.
Na ja,
egal.
Ich gebe jetzt hier einfach alle Zutaten in die Küchenmaschine.
Ihr könnt den Teig aber auch gerne per Hand verkneten.
Ich glaube, das sieht jetzt ziemlich cool aus.
[Musik]
>> JOSH: Warte! Was hast du?
>> SALLY: Sehr, sehr, sehr
vertan.
Ich hatte zuerst zu wenig Mehl.
Ich schreibe euch die geänderte Mehlangabe
direkt in die App und in den Blog.
Denn ich hatte die Flüssigkeiten zusammengezählt
und den Spinat dazu
und habe dann vergessen, die Mehlmenge zu erhöhen.
Weil das war ja jetzt auch doch recht flüssig.
Zack!
Und wenn sich alles verbunden hat schon ein bisschen,
dann erst Fett dazu geben und auch Salz.
Denn Fett und Salz sollten nie direkt zur Hefe,
damit sie einfach ihre
Geheigenschaft nicht verliert.
Und jetzt einfach den Hefeteig für etwa
fünf bis zehn Minuten kneten,
bis er schön geschmeidig ist.
Das sieht so krass aus, diese Farbe!
So sieht der Teig jetzt aus.
Und ich muss sagen, er ist schön geschmeidig,
klebt aber auch ein bisschen.
Ich mache die später nämlich in Burgerringen.
Wenn ihr jetzt aber sagt,
"Mensch, ich will mir die Burger Buns lieber formen",
so, wie ich es in meinem klassischen
Burger-Bun-Rezept gemacht habe,
dann gebt einfach noch ein bisschen mehr Mehl dazu
oder weniger Flüssigkeit.
Macht einen Teig,
der einfach schön geschmeidig und schön weich ist,
aber eben nicht mehr klebt.
Und dann kann man die Burger Buns auch schön formen.
So. Ich gucke jetzt mal hier.
Aber hier hat sich alles wunderbar verbunden.
Ich werde ihn jetzt abdecken,
bis zum doppelten Volumen aufgehen lassen,
das heißt entweder eine Stunde bei Raumtemperatur
oder im warmen Backofen
oder 30 Minuten bei Gärstufe, also mit Wasserdampf.
So trocknet die Oberfläche nicht aus.
Und dann geht es damit gleich weiter.
So sieht der Teig jetzt aus,
wabbelig.
Also ich muss sagen,
sieht gewöhnungsbedürftig aus.
Aber ich finde es gut.
Denn ich werde jetzt, wie gesagt, in Burgerringen backen.
Daher setze ich mir die jetzt schon mal hierher.
Da passen so immer so sechs Stück ungefähr auf das Blech.
Zack, zack!
Und, wie gesagt, wenn ihr sie per Hand formen wollt,
einfach den Teig etwas knetfähiger machen.
Ich besprühe jetzt trotzdem meine Hände mit Backtrennspray.
Denn ich versuche zumindest
– also ich nehme jetzt immer so 100 Gramm.
So 80 bis 100 Gramm sind wirklich perfekt.
Dann sind sie auch nicht zu groß.
Und ich versuche...
Mh.
Ich glaube, es geht doch nicht so, wie ich mir das dachte.
Nein.
Ich wollte eine glatte Oberfläche machen,
aber es geht nicht.
Okay, dann fülle ich es einfach hier rein.
Weil ich fand die letzten Burger eigentlich auch
gar nicht so schlecht.
Die hatten jetzt nicht die megaglatte Oberfläche,
aber, hey, sie sehen selbst gemacht aus.
Okay, das hätte ich mir jetzt echt sparen können.
Njam, njam, njam.
Ich tu kurz Hände waschen, Josh.
[Musik]
Geht.
Man kriegt es sogar ein bisschen rund.
Einfach mit so zwei Teigkarten
so von unten,
wie wenn man es mit den Fingern rollen würde.
Zack, zack!
Und ablegen.
[Musik]
Und jetzt könnt ihr die Burger Buns sozusagen
mit ein bisschen Backtrennspray oder Öl einpinseln.
Backtrennspray ist ja auch vegan,
weil es wirklich nur Kokosfett und Rapsöl ist.
So ein bisschen einsprühen die Oberfläche
und dann glätten,
also die ganze Form ausfüllen.
Und dann dürfen sie gerne noch mal aufgehen.
So werden sie richtig locker.
[Musik]
Nach dem Aufgehen bestreiche ich jetzt hier die Burger noch
– also die Teige –
noch mal mit veganer Milch.
Also ich habe ja hier jetzt eine Hafermilch.
Eigelb bleibt jetzt hier weg.
Aber das gibt mir jetzt auch noch mal
so ein bisschen Feuchtigkeit im Backofen.
Ihr könnt nämlich
entweder jetzt die Brote mit Dampfstoß noch backen,
wenn ihr einen Dampfofen habt,
oder noch mal ein Schälchen mit Wasser reinstellen
oder mit Wasser besprühen.
Aber, wie gesagt, wenn ihr das hier so bestreicht,
habt ihr auch schon wirklich ganz viel Feuchtigkeit.
Und jetzt könnt ihr sie bestreuen mit Sesam
oder auch mit Schwarzkümmel oder mit schwarzem Sesam,
ganz, wie ihr möchtet.
Jetzt werden sie gebacken und danach direkt
mit einem Tuch abgedeckt, sodass sie abkühlen dürfen.
Ich finde beides cool.
Das hat was von Burger.
Das hat was von so Halloween-Burger.
Und jetzt in den vorgeheizten Backofen
und schön durchbacken.
Und jetzt gar nicht bei so hoher Hitze.
Denn sie sollen nicht braun werden,
sondern eben auch grün bleiben.
[Musik]
Die Burger Buns sind jetzt gebacken und abgekühlt.
Und jetzt könnt ihr sie aus dem Ring rauslösen,
einfach mit einer Palette zum Beispiel
hier am Rand entlang.
Und für uns ist es jetzt heute schon
ein bisschen spät geworden.
Das heißt, bei uns geht es morgen weiter.
Die Brötchen habe ich jetzt sozusagen gebacken.
Und ihr seht auch,
sie sind schön luftig und locker.
Und dann gibt es morgen bei uns
Veggie-Burger.
Und ich freue mich schon darauf.
Ich decke die jetzt ab
und lasse sie einfach hier ruhen.
Und dann machen wir morgen früh direkt den Pattie
– den oder das? –
das,
das Pattie.
[Musik]
So. Willkommen zurück!
Die Burger Buns sind, wie gesagt, gebacken.
Jetzt mache ich die Patties, also den Fleischersatz.
Und wir haben das wirklich auch schon ganz oft gemacht.
Die Schwierigkeit für mich lag jetzt nur darin,
alles für euch abzumessen.
Denn normalerweise gucken wir,
was wir einfach an Gemüse dahaben
schmeißen alles in die Pfanne
– sogar Salat von gestern oder vorgestern –
und es wird einfach alles angebraten.
Ich denke aber, die Menge, die passt jetzt so.
Ich zeige euch jetzt mal, was ich ausgesucht habe.
Aber ihr könnt im Prinzip, wenn ihr sagt,
"Ich mag absolut keine Karotten",
dann nehmt halt keine Karotten
oder keine Zucchini.
Nehmt einfach Gemüse, was ihr eben so dahabt.
Und diese Patties,
die kann man auf unterschiedlichste Art und Weise machen,
auf Bohnenbasis, auf Sojabasis,
auf Basis von Linsen, Kichererbsen und so weiter.
Ich habe jetzt hier nur eine Variante.
Und wenn die euch super schmeckt,
dann könnt ihr die ausprobieren und eben machen.
Ansonsten können wir gerne auch noch weitere testen.
Ich verwende jetzt
20 Gramm Sonnenblumenöl,
zwei Zwiebeln,
zwei Knoblauchzehen,
200 Gramm Karotten,
Zucchini.
Hier habe ich 200 Gramm Champignons,
100 Gramm Linsen,
– die sind bereits gewaschen –
100 Gramm Wasser.
Hier habe ich noch die Gewürze.
Ich nehme Rauchsalz,
etwas Paprikapulver in edelsüß
und Pfeffer
und 150 Gramm Haferflocken.
Das sind jetzt zarte Haferflocken,
aber auch die kernigen gehen wunderbar.
Im Prinzip müsst ihr jetzt nicht viel beachten,
sondern das Gemüse einfach nur fein schneiden.
Ihr könnt es schneiden oder direkt vermixen.
Ich mache das jetzt hier gleich im Mixer.
Geht einfach superschnell.
Und ich brauche später eben auch einen Mixer,
um die Masse noch mal zu zerkleinern.
Die Karotten, die sind bio.
Daher habe ich sie jetzt gewaschen
und kann sie mit Schale verwenden.
Ich schneide nur diesen Strunk da weg.
Zack!
Knoblauchzehen brauche ich gar nicht zerkleinern.
Bei der Zucchini auch nur hinten und vorne wegschneiden.
Ich habe jetzt hier einfach Gemüse ausgewählt.
Teilweise ist es sehr wässrig, wie jetzt Zucchini zum Beispiel.
Aber, wie gesagt, das verkocht später alles.
Die Champignons noch halbieren.
Ich hatte ja kurz überlegt, Rote Bete reinzugeben,
dass ich ein rotes Pattie habe.
Aber ich habe mich doch dazu entschlossen,
Rote Bete später als Spiralnudeln so drauf zu geben.
So. Das war es erst mal.
Jetzt kommt alles hier oben rein
auf einmal oder auf zweimal.
[Musik]
Jetzt kann ich hier das Öl in meine Pfanne geben
und gebe schon mal den ersten Schwung hier rein.
Wenn ihr jetzt keinen Mixer habt, ist gar nicht schlimm.
Dann hackt euer Gemüse einfach schön fein.
Dann geht das auch.
[Musik]
Also es sieht tatsächlich schöner aus,
wenn man es klein hackt
und nicht zu Brei püriert.
Aber es kommt später auf das Gleiche raus.
Daher jetzt einfach anbraten.
Den Rest zerkleinere ich jetzt auch noch
[Musik]
So sieht es schon ästhetischer aus.
Jetzt bratet ihr das Gemüse schön an.
Dadurch bekommt es Röstaromen,
verliert auch seine Flüssigkeit.
Aber es geht jetzt hier erst mal um den Geschmack,
also wirklich um die Röstaromen.
Und das dauert jetzt einfach so ein paar Minuten.
[Musik]
Das Gemüse ist jetzt schön geröstet.
Und ich habe es wirklich ganz scharf angebraten.
Ich habe jetzt hier die Wassermenge doch etwas erhöht.
Denn ich habe jetzt hier noch Linsen,
die noch kochen müssen beziehungsweise quellen müssen.
Die habe ich schon gewaschen.
Die kommen jetzt hier rein.
Wir haben es auch schon ohne Linsen gemacht.
War auch superlecker.
Aber so hat man einfach noch mal Hülsenfrüchte mit dabei,
schön Eiweiß mit dabei.
Jetzt hier das Wasser rein.
Und dann lasse ich das jetzt hier kochen,
bis die Linsen gar sind.
Mit Deckel natürlich.
Da stelle ich jetzt die Hitze auch runter.
Und das dauert jetzt so ungefähr 15 bis 20 Minuten.
Wenn ihr merkt, die Linsen sind noch nicht durch,
aber es fehlt noch ein bisschen Flüssigkeit,
dann gebt einfach noch Wasser dazu.
Aber ich denke, bei uns dürfte es gerade passen.
Denn es soll ja nicht flüssig sein,
sondern eher dann so eine Breikonsistenz haben.
So.
Oh! Ich kann schon mal
die Crème fraîche vorbereiten
und die Rote Bete vorbereiten.
Das machen wir jetzt in der Zwischenzeit.
Für die Rote Bete habe ich jetzt hier
einfach nur zwei, drei Zutaten.
Ich nehme einmal frische Rote Bete,
rote Zwiebeln,
etwas Olivenöl
Salz und Pfeffer
und Balsamico.
Das habe ich jetzt vergessen rauszustellen.
Ich habe auch alles improvisiert.
Und davon nehmen wir etwa 40 Gramm.
Ihr könnt jetzt die Zwiebel und die Rote Bete
– ah, erst mal müsst ihr Handschuhe anziehen,
außer ihr wollt pinkfarbene Hände.
Könnt ihr auch gerne machen.
Aber ich ziehe jetzt Handschuhe an.
Jetzt habe ich pinkfarbene Handschuhe.
Und ihr könnt dann
die Rote Bete erst mal schälen.
Ich mache das aber hier im Teller,
damit sich mein Schneidebrett nicht verfärbt.
Und entweder reibt ihr sie dann zu dünnen Stiften,
also so Juliennestifte,
oder ihr macht wirklich Spirellis daraus.
Und ich mache so Spiralnudeln daraus,
weil es später superschön aussieht.
Ich hatte auch mal
– das ist richtig lange her –
einen Halloween-Burger gemacht
und hatte da auch so Rote Bete drauf.
Das war auch schon ziemlich schön.
Hier drunter sieht es übrigens auch richtig gut aus.
Das gart so vor sich hin.
Und die Linsen sehen auch schon gut aus.
Aber die brauchen noch ein paar Minuten.
Aber bis dahin bin ich dann hier fertig.
So.
Jetzt gehe ich doch auf das Schneidebrett.
Aber ich wische es dann einfach gleich weg.
Ich mache das hier oben mal weg
und hier.
Den Part nehme ich aber
und benutze ihn morgen früh im Smoothie.
Denn ich liebe Rote Bete!
Zack!
Also ich habe hier so einen Spiralschneider.
Gibt es auch als Aufsatz für die Kenwood oder die KitchenAid.
Aber ich mache das jetzt hier händisch.
[Musik]
Ich gebe die hier schon mal in meine Pfanne.
Denn ich habe eine Riesen-Rote-Bete-Knolle erwischt.
[Musik]
Sieht schon cool aus.
Aber, ich glaube, das reicht tatsächlich schon.
Die Zwiebel, die schneide ich jetzt auch hier kurz.
[Musik]
Dann gehe ich jetzt hier direkt an die Pfanne,
gebe die Zwiebeln auch mit dazu.
Dann kann ich das hier kurz anbraten.
Und da kommt jetzt das Olivenöl dazu.
Und dann bratet ihr die Masse
so für etwa ein bis zwei Minuten an.
[Musik]
Ich würze jetzt hier noch mit Salz und Pfeffer.
Ich muss sagen, ich habe etwas Angst,
dass der Balsamico-Essig die schöne Farbe zerstört.
Huch!
Deswegen lasse ich den jetzt doch weg
und schalte jetzt hier den Herd aus.
>> ELA: Rote Bete!
>> SALLY: Magst du Rote Bete?
>> ELA: Nein.
>> SALLY: Deswegen. Ich schalte jetzt den Herd aus,
lasse es hier so.
Es darf ruhig noch ein bisschen Biss haben.
Mit Salz und Pfeffer ist es gewürzt.
Und ich bereite jetzt noch kurz
die Crème fraîche vor.
Denn das hier braucht noch ein, zwei Minütchen.
Ich habe jetzt hier vegane Crème fraîche.
Und ich muss echt sagen,
die sieht furchtbar echt aus.
Also die habe ich jetzt einfach im Supermarkt gekauft.
Eine Marke brauche ich nicht nennen.
Denn ich glaube, da gibt es einfach verschiedene Marken.
Das ist jetzt eine auf Soja- und Mandelbasis.
Und ich probiere die jetzt auch gleich.
Weil ich finde, irgendwie was Cremiges
muss da jetzt schon rein.
Ansonsten könnte man jetzt auch noch Ajvar dazu nehmen
oder einfach Hummus oder so ähnlich.
Aber ich finde, so
das passt jetzt geschmacklich wahrscheinlich ganz gut.
Ich habe jetzt hier noch etwas Schnittlauch aus dem Garten.
Crème fraîche und Schnittlauch sind nämlich auch
so ziemlich beste Freunde.
Und ich glaube, Josh und ich, wir sind jetzt beide
mal gespannt auf die vegane Crème fraîche.
So.
Und noch mit Salz und Pfeffer abschmecken.
Hier muss jetzt die Creme
auch nicht so einen starken Geschmack haben.
Denn, wenn ich normalerweise Burger mache,
dann würze ich das Rindfleisch nicht.
Das heißt, ich habe einfach Rindfleisch ohne Salz und Pfeffer
und gucke dann schon,
dass die Soße ein bisschen würziger ist.
Aber hier habe ich ja jetzt diesen würzigen
Gemüse-Pattie.
Und da kommt ja auch gleich gut Gewürz mit rein.
Von daher
muss das hier im Prinzip ganz normal abgeschmeckt werden.
Wow!
>> JOSH: Hammer!
>> SALLY: Der schmeckt so gar nicht wie
– okay, im Nachgeschmack,
so im Nachgeschmack.
Aber...
>> JOSH: Also mir könntest du es komplett unterjubeln.
>> SALLY: Also, wenn ich da jetzt noch Knoblauch reinhaue,
– hauen würde,
was ich jetzt nicht tu, weil ich immer Knoblauch habe –
könnte man es nicht unterscheiden.
Also das ist echt ein cooles, tolles veganes Produkt.
Ein bisschen Salz gebe ich noch dazu.
Das war es.
Und jetzt geht es schon weiter
mit den Patties.
Also die Linsen sind jetzt auch weich.
Ein bisschen Flüssigkeit ist noch drin.
Das ist aber auch gut so.
Ich habe jetzt hier Rauchsalz, Pfeffer und Paprika.
Es gibt auch Rauchpaprika.
Das ist auch immer ganz cool.
Ich denke, so bekommt man einfach
so diesen würzigen, rauchigen Geschmack mit rein,
den Burger eben normalerweise haben.
Und hier könnt ihr gerne auch noch Kräuter mit dazu geben,
Gewürze mit dazu geben,
was ihr möchtet.
Ich probiere es jetzt mal so
und schmecke dann auch die Masse gleich ab.
Und da die jetzt so nicht bindet,
brauche ich eben die Haferflocken.
Die kommen jetzt hier mit rein.
Und damit die jetzt auch binden, werden sie noch mal püriert.
Und dann sollte es wirklich super
mit diesem Kleister auch funktionieren,
mit diesem Haferkleister.
Wenn wir mit dem Volkan kochen, ist es immer ganz witzig,
weil es passiert einfach alles dann immer so spontan und
es wird viel improvisiert:
Dies könnte noch passen und das könnte noch passen.
Paprika haben wir oft noch mit dabei.
Das ist wirklich immer so ein tolles Resteessen.
Das könnte man oft nicht meinen.
Und, was wir auch schon hatten,
hat der Josh auch mal mitgebracht.
Der hat auch schon solche veganen Patties gemacht
und dann einfach nicht als Pattie geformt.
Wir hatten auch schon mal so Bällchen geformt
mit einem Eisportionierer
und dann eingefroren und einfach in Wraps dann rein,
also einfach noch mal gegrillt oder ausgebacken
und dann in Wraps reingelegt.
Das schmeckt auch voll lecker!
[Musik]
Also ich muss noch ein bisschen Haferflocken dazu geben,
weil es einfach jetzt so eine breiige Konsistenz hat,
aber ich will es ja gleich formen.
[Musik]
So.
Die Masse gebe ich jetzt hier auf ein Blech,
damit sie einfach schnell abkühlt,
damit ich sie auch gleich formen kann.
Und ihr seht, die Konsistenz ist jetzt schön fest.
Und so kann ich sie nach dem Kühlen
auch auf jeden Fall formen.
Also jetzt könnt ihr sie
entweder bei Raumtemperatur stehen lassen
oder kurz in den Kühlschrank geben,
was aber nicht so ganz energieeffizient ist.
Deswegen lasse ich sie jetzt hier einfach
bei Raumtemperatur kurz abkühlen.
Und dann sehen wir uns gleich wieder.
Die Masse ist jetzt abgekühlt.
Und ihr seht auch, von der Konsistenz her ist sie relativ fest.
So soll es ja auch sein.
An der Stelle bitte abschmecken,
ob noch Salz fehlt oder Pfeffer oder noch Kräuter.
Die Masse muss euch jetzt so schon schmecken.
Im Prinzip wäre sie auch schon verzehrbereit.
Also ihr könnt die so auch schon aufs Brot streichen.
Aber nein, wir machen Burger daraus.
Ich habe jetzt hier schon eine beschichtete Pfanne erwärmt.
Denn bei uns geht es jetzt gleich mit dem Burgerbraten los.
Denn es ist schon wieder relativ spät
und wir wollen jetzt einfach essen.
Also ich fette meine Hände mit etwas Sonnenblumenöl.
Und ich denke, von der Größe her brauche ich schon so zwei
Eisportionierer voll für einen Pattie.
Und guckt mal!
Und als ich es
– ich habe ja gesagt, ich habe das auch schon gemacht
in Wraps rein.
Ich habe einfach so gemacht
und habe sie so praktisch auf ein Blech und eingefroren.
Und dann konnte ich die so einfach ausbacken
und hatte wirklich ganz, ganz schnell was für Wraps.
Aber heute machen wir Patties.
Denn es sollen Burger werden.
Also einfach in der Handfläche
so ein bisschen platt drücken.
Geht auch ganz schnell.
Ich denke, eine Burgerpresse würde sich hier auch anbieten.
Aber so geht es auch gut.
Ich denke, der sollte jetzt auch gar nicht so wirklich schrumpfen.
Und dann kommt das bei mir hier zumindest
schon mal direkt in die Pfanne.
Ich werde die restlichen auch gleich parallel zubereiten.
[Musik]
Ich backe die Gemüse-Patties jetzt hier einfach
bei mittelhoher Hitze in einer beschichteten Pfanne
mit ein bisschen Öl
einfach für etwa drei Minuten von jeder Seite aus.
Achtet einfach darauf, dass sie nicht zu dunkel werden.
Also so wie hier haben sie
eigentlich schon eine schöne Bräune.
Und dann
werde ich gleich das Burgerbrot erwärmen.
Das mache ich hier drüben.
Und dann setzen wir den Burger gleich zusammen.
Und ich bin echt schon gespannt darauf, wie er schmeckt.
[Musik]
Okay.
Also wir machen das jetzt so.
Ich habe hier gerade nämlich schon den Dennis sitzen.
Dennis ist ja
sozusagen ein neuer Veganer,
also noch gar nicht so lang.
Dennis, seit wann?
>> DENNIS: Fünf Monate schon.
>> SALLY: Fünf Monate schon?
>> DENNIS: Ja.
>> SALLY: Wahnsinn!
>> DENNIS: Also knapp fünf. Ja.
Also es kommt halt jetzt darauf an, aber
Anfang, Ende Januar ging es los.
>> SALLY: Ja. Der Volkan ist ja schon seit,
ich glaube, drei Jahren oder so,
seit drei Jahren Veganer.
Das kann sein.
Ich werde das Brot noch kurz erwärmen.
Aber ich finde, so das Farbzusammenspiel schon cool
so zwischen Grün, Rot, Orange.
>> DENNIS: Was gibt es denn Leckeres?
Ich sehe Burger.
>> SALLY: Es gibt Burger.
Und ich dachte, wir machen die
schon ein bisschen auch speziell.
Und du weißt, ich meine, ich mag ja auch veganes Essen.
Aber ich mag es nicht,
wenn halt praktisch Produkte ersetzt werden,
die ich dann halt auch nicht gesund finde.
>> DENNIS: Ja.
>> SALLY: Also so...
Ich weiß nicht.
Soja, bin ich jetzt auch nicht so der Fan, muss nicht sein.
Es gibt auch gute Sojaprodukte.
Um Himmels Willen.
Das will ich gar nicht verteufeln.
Aber
ich habe jetzt mal Gemüse-Patties
selber gemacht.
Die Burger Buns...
>> DENNIS: Das erinnert mich an saure Schlangen
>> SALLY: Ja!
>> DENNIS: in meiner Kindheit.
>> SALLY: Die sind mmh!
>> DENNIS: Boah, ey!
Ich habe die immer so...
>> SALLY: Lecker!
>> DENNIS: Aber die sind nicht vegan.
Und die werden jetzt vegan.
>> SALLY: Die sind vegan. Ja.
Ich habe hier übrigens jetzt doch noch Essig drauf,
zwar keinen Balsamico, aber so einen hellen Apfelessig.
Ihr könnt auch einen hellen Balsamico nehmen.
Geschmacklich hat es mir einfach doch gefehlt.
Und Spinat.
Den habe ich schon gewaschen und geschleudert.
Deswegen sieht er so ein bisschen trocken aus.
Und die habe ich auch mit Spinat sozusagen verfeinert.
>> DENNIS: Hm.
>> SALLY: Ich bin selber...
Ich habe noch keinen Bestandteil probiert.
Also wir gucken jetzt.
>> DENNIS: Also das ist sozusagen ein Livetest?
Ich bin so ein Proband?
>> SALLY: Ja.
Das Brot muss noch kurz warm werden.
>> DENNIS: Was ist das für eine Soße jetzt?
>> SALLY: Crème fraîche vegan.
Da kam ich auf die Idee, weil ich in deiner Story
die vegane Crème fraîche gesehen habe
>> DENNIS: Ah!
>> SALLY: und ihr gesagt habt, die schmeckt gut.
>> DENNIS: Die ist die beste!
>> SALLY: Und die schmeckt echt gut.
>> DENNIS: Die ist wirklich sehr, sehr, sehr gut!
>> SALLY: Die ist echt gut.
Okay.
>> DENNIS: Ich bin gespannt.
>> SALLY: Dann das hier.
>> ELA: Mama!
>> SALLY: Ja, Ela?
>> ELA: Kann ich den Webrahmen haben, Mama?
>> SALLY: Der ist – ich gucke gleich, Schatzi.
Ich glaube, ich würde jetzt halt
alles so ein bisschen mit Crème fraîche.
>> DENNIS: Ja.
Das ist auch immer ganz gut,
>> SALLY: Hach! Ich habe was vergessen.
>> DENNIS: dass es nicht zu trocken ist.
>> SALLY: Ja, nicht?
>> DENNIS: Was denn?
Ach!
>> JOSH: Da drüben ist die geheime Rezeptur schon.
>> DENNIS: Was war das?!
Wolltest du jetzt gerade so einen hier machen?
So einen Backflip?
>> SALLY: Ich wollte hier Spinat darunter machen
und dann wollte ich es kurz noch mal wegsetzen.
>> DENNIS: Das sah gerade anders aus.
Das war so: Patsch!
"Ah!"
Das war aber auf dem Boden.
Aber es ist ein Smiley.
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> DENNIS: Es fehlen nur die Augen.
>> SALLY: Also
>> DENNIS: Die sind da.
>> SALLY: dann das drauf.
Ich wollte nämlich, dass Grün drunter ist.
Weil ich habe da schon einen Burger aufgemalt,
wie ich ihn haben will.
>> DENNIS: Ah, okay.
>> SALLY: Okay.
Also es tut mir leid für den unästhetisch Anblick.
>> DENNIS: Kein Problem. Ist okay.
>> SALLY: Es tut mir leid.
Ich habe...
In meinem Zeugnis würde jetzt stehen: "Sie hat sich
>> DENNIS: Stets bemüht.
>> SALLY: stets bemüht."
>> DENNIS: Ja, steht auch, glaube ich, drin.
>> SALLY: Schreibst du mir das?
>> DENNIS: Nee, aber ich habe da mal was gehört.
Aber ist egal.
>> SALLY: Okay.
So.
Uh, fast verbrannt.
Fast
>> DENNIS: Stets bemüht.
>> SALLY: das Brot verbrannt.
Jetzt kann ich damit das gar nicht mehr drehen.
>> DENNIS: Ich habe heute meinen Austeiltag.
>> SALLY: Ja, ich merke es schon
[Musik]
>> DENNIS: Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh!
Ich knie nieder!
Okay, alles wieder gut gemacht.
>> SALLY: Like a Boss.
>> DENNIS: Das war eben echt Boss.
Ich kann das – ich traue mich das nicht.
>> SALLY: Das war ein Boss Move.
>> DENNIS: Der war echt gut.
>> SALLY: Der war echt nicht schlecht.
>> DENNIS: Den müsstest du eigentlich in Slow-Mo
so aufnehmen, weil du hast noch so: Bam!
>> SALLY: Das machen wir gleich.
>> DENNIS: Wow!
Voll cool!
>> SALLY: Also das ist mein veganer Burger.
[Musik]
>> DENNIS: Lecker!
>> SALLY: Aber komm. Sieht schon cool aus!
>> DENNIS: Sieht mega aus!
>> SALLY: Cool war vor allem,
die Samira vorhin so: "Mama, woah cool!
Hast du die gefärbt mit Lebensmittelfarbe?"
Und ich: "Ja, ja, mit Lebensmittelfarbe."
Hätte ich jetzt gesagt "Spinat", hätte sie gesagt:
>> SALLY & DENNIS: "Bäh!"
>> DENNIS: Hm.
>> SALLY: So wie bei grünen Nudeln.
Aber, sobald etwas quietschgrün oder quietschrot ist,
findet sie es cool.
Okay. Komm, wir probieren.
>> DENNIS: Echt lecker!
>> SALLY: Was ich fairerweise dazu sagen muss,
>> DENNIS: Schmeckt gut.
>> SALLY: bei so einem normalen Burger hat man ja
– das Fleisch, das hat noch so eine andere Konsistenz.
Also
>> DENNIS: Hm.
>> SALLY: die Konsistenz trifft es jetzt nicht,
aber geschmacklich finde ich es echt genial.
>> DENNIS: Mh.
Ich muss sagen,
also ich finde die Konsistenz jetzt nicht schlecht.
>> SALLY: Mhm.
>> DENNIS: Also da habe ich schon
schlimmere Patties gegessen,
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> DENNIS: vegane.
Ich finde die jetzt...
Ich probiere, mache jetzt noch mal.
Mmh!
>> SALLY: Ich hätte sie einfach länger ausbacken können.
Dann wird er auch noch mal fester.
>> DENNIS: Hm.
>> SALLY: Aber echt cool!
Und wenn man ein bisschen Biss haben will,
kann man ja auch die Linsen noch im Ganzen lassen,
nicht pürieren,
die Haferflocken einfach einrühren.
Dann hat man auch mehr Biss.
Dann ist nicht alles so Brei,
sondern wirklich noch ein bisschen fester.
Also ich finde es cool.
Wenn ihr das Rezept ausprobieren wollt,
testet es gerne mal auch als Nicht-Veganer.
Und so
könnte ich, glaube ich, auch schon den Murat damit
überzeugen.
>> DENNIS: Auf jeden Fall.
>> SALLY: Und ich finde die grünen Brötchen echt cool!
Den Rest können wir einfrieren
und können uns jederzeit Burger grillen.
>> DENNIS: Burger Time!
>> SALLY: Burger Time!
>> DENNIS: Hallo!
>> ELA: Kannst du mir lauter machen, Mama?
>> SALLY: Also viel Spaß beim Nachmachen!
Bis zum nächsten Mal!
Tschüss!
[Musik]
Also so habe ich den Burger geplant.
Und so ist er geworden.
Schon ziemlich cool!
Wie auf dem Bild.
Original.
Wir haben Besuch.
Ich habe gerade die Tür geöffnet, weil die Post kam.
Und mit dem Öffnen der Tür kam Frieda,
die kleine Schnecke.
Das ist Frieda, die kleine Schnecke.
Ich habe die mal eine Zeit lang gezüchtet.
Weil in Biologie in der siebten oder achten Klasse
haben wir einen Film über Schnecken gedreht.
Ja, ich war damals schon sehr medienaffin.
Mit meiner Freundin Jana und Anna,
mit meinen zwei Freundinnen
haben wir Schnecken gezüchtet.
Und das waren meine Haustiere.
Und dann haben wir so eine Glasscheibe genommen
und haben so, wie sie sich so da hochschlängelt
und so mit ihrer Schleimspur.
Ja, irgendwann finde ich dieses Material wieder
und dann zeige ich euch das.
Also
hallo, Frieda!
Ich möchte ja, dass es dir gut geht.
Deswegen setze ich dich jetzt nach draußen
in unser Hochbeet. Okay?
Da darfst du alles essen, was du möchtest!
Ja?